Online safety bill was the first
comprehensive piece of legislation that
aims to kind of formalize the
relationship between the state and
social media companies in essence what
it does is creates some legal duties on
large social media companies
particularly around this notion of a
duty of care and so social media
companies in the UK now have a series of
legal obligations as to what they must
and must not do and on the surface of it
some of this sounds very sensible things
like they must take down illegal content
and their rules about they have to make
policies for how they take down illegal
content how quickly they do it can they
prevent it going online in the first
place things like that which sounds
sensible and to some degree it is and
you certainly you need to have them
involved with law enforcement to some
degree but what the bill does is
effectively makes these private
companies private police so they're
adjudicating what's unlawful